[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is an
economist and the co-author of a
brilliant book that Francis and I have
just read and really enjoyed anger in
omics Mike Blythe welcome to
trigonometry it's wonderful to be with
you I'm so sorry you couldn't find
someone interesting and you got me
instead yeah well you do yourself a
disservice me because as I said having
read your book I think our audience who
actually have been clamoring for us to
get you on the show for some time I'm
gonna enjoy this conversation but for
anyone who hasn't been clamoring I took
for us to get you on the show which is
not many people just tell everybody a
little bit about who you are how are you
where you are what has been the journey
that leads you to be talking to two
comedians on YouTube all right short
version of that when I was 13 years old
that's all an episode of oh sure it was
panorama and back in about 1981 and they
set up a game show between two
economists they did this [ __ ] back then
and one was like this old guy in a tweed
jacket and looked like everybody's
favorite old lefty professor and it was
another look who was wearing the kind of
spell suit of the you know who was about
30 and he was from the London Business
School the other guy was Manchester one
hunters qingzi and model with a billion
equations and a household sector
knowledge so the other was a monetarist
model and sex equations in it and the
right answer was always tax cut right no
I may have been 13 buy a new horse [ __ ]
when I saw it and I thought oh I want to
study this because this seems like fun
so variously through staff flight and
then at Columbia my PhD is in political
science but I study economics as a thing
in the world not as a theory of the
world because I think it's there for
both good and evil
and we often weaponize economic ideas to
get what we want and use them as
justifications but in moments like this
this chaos moment of covert we look to
models we look to see these to tell us
what to do in moments of deep
uncertainty and that's when they become
really interesting and really powerful
so that's basically what I study my
short is by
who says I study uncertainty and
randomness and complex systems and
wonder why people believe [ __ ]
economic ideas despite pockets of
evidence to the contrary hmm
well that sounds like a perfect setup so
one of the things you talk about with
your co-author
in the book is the different versions of
capitalism so we've just finished were
you or maybe not finished tell us we've
just lived through a period which you
call capitalism 3.00 just tell us mark
where were we before the pandemic hit
just describe for anyone who hasn't read
ebook good maybe he's not an economist
what was the world that we've been
living through what did it look like so
the most common way that people talk
about this is they call it the
neoliberal world I'm not sure if that's
the best way to think about it but
essentially here's how I think about it
when you came out at the Great
Depression in World War two there was
one job for governments did a lot of you
were left right sainted or anything you
had to do full employment because you'd
been through a half a generation of
unemployment that resulted in fascism
and the death of 50 million it wasn't
clear that capitalism was going to
survive you had a Soviet Union had
abolished unemployment and stopped the
Nazi tanks it was an attractive offer to
everybody else on the other side and
basically capitalism at a reformed
itself and the way it did this was to
make full employment the policy target
and we had 20 years almost 30 years a
very good growth very good growth for
workers in terms of real wages the
problem with that very rate labor
friendly order is that if you basically
guaranteed maximum employment for a very
long period of time the dumbest guy you
know can leave their office and get a
better paid job by four o'clock that's
gonna constantly bed up wages the way
that employers respond is with prices
the result inflation the 1970s when you
have inflation if you'da capitalist
there's a nightmare
because if I'm investing and expect then
I got a 5% rate at a ton of inflation
goes to 10% and might as well take the
money around the back of the house and
bonnet so essentially capital went on a
capital strike stopped investing
unemployment show up political parties
of the right said enough bus that we'd
not doing this deal anymore and what did
they do privatize integrate globalize
all in the buzzwords of the past 30
years to create a much more
open liberal ordinal now in many ways
this was actually a great thing an
increased massive per-capita GDP growth
around the world but one of his more
pernicious effects was median wages and
lower end wages in the developed
countries went down very simple way to
think about it if you had 700 million
people the global labor pool your wages
are gonna go down it's as simple as that
so along with technological changes that
favor big companies particularly digital
companies etc we ended up in a
classically unequal world no inequality
doesn't really mark the most people so
long as it's relative that is to say I'm
going up and you're going up at the same
time but if you're going up and I'm
going down or when you have a big shock
like 2008 when the whole buffer system
below is up in a box blow-up if you then
tongue run and be do basically what was
capitalism for the poor and socialism
for the right
you'd be alike those who have the assets
and then stick the cost on everybody
else and becomes of austerity policies
which is exactly what happened now
you're going to have a lot of pissed-off
people if you then in the British
context do the Scottish project this
project fear don't ever leave no matter
how [ __ ] is if you never do that again
with brexit whatever you do don't do it
don't whatever the elites tell you
because they're the ones I've been
making off like bandits for the past 30
years you haven't but honestly this is
the best of all possible worlds then
eventually people get a bit skeptical
and they get a little bit annoyed and
also they get the notice the fragility
in their lives and if you add to this
the fact that we've got an aging society
right low productivity society we've got
huge amounts of technological change
that demand that all the stuff we're
already doing at work we have to be more
adaptive we've got gig economy we have
to be flexible all the time and then
essentially all the costs are falling on
to us and then covert hits and what you
see isn't exactly a huge expanse of
these tendencies because people like me
who can walk from holding hood at the
top of the tree we're not made
unemployed we're made more invaluable
right people who recall essential
workers they're the ones that are
getting paid 10 quite a now or who are
risking their lives whether it's in meat
factories Amazon ware houses shops right
they're the ones who are keeping it
going and what do you find again this
huge dispersal and wages this huge
dispersal in the earnings of firms it
just gets worse and that creates a very
tense and very
in fraps at society and that's what we
saw just before cool bird remember chili
riots Hong Kong riots France
Yellowjackets Breton brags her America
Trump supporters barely support us the
whole place was kicking off and it was
kicking off for a good reason it was
becoming harder and harder for ordinary
people just to hold their daily [ __ ]
together and do what they need to do
with the families and they said that
pasta enough we're not doing this
anymore among what you're describing
seems to me like a crisis do you think
that the West in particular had reached
a crisis point just before Kovac I think
you're hard but we're really good at
covering up we're covered up two ways
one is emotional live that is to say we
always pin it on ourselves stick it on
my back a little bit more mustn't
grumble just keep going a little but
it's fine things will be okay and the
other way we do that is with credit we
basically did massive credit expansion
and you know I don't really worry that
much about public debt for the simple
reason that when is a crisis people dump
shares they don't want to hold equities
they want to see facets the C fossa is
the government bond which is why now the
British government despite everything
they're doing have a negative real
interest rate on a 10 your debt which is
not so when you think about it
I worry a bit private there and what we
did was leave a corporate debt on top of
a credit card there on top of
educational day and ordinary people's
wages weren't growing think about coming
at a university just before covert right
and you've gone into a flat labor market
we just aren't rising even for
university graduates you got possibly 40
grand worth in debt and your chances of
buying a house in London even if you
save every penny you've got over the
next 10 years are zero why should
anybody think this is a success story
and I mean it does sound fairly bleak
when you explain it like that but surely
people would argue look you know things
have never been better look at the
technical advances look at the way you
know societies become ever more equal
haven't things been improving what do
you think we've actually been regression
it's a bit of both my favorite line and
this comes from one of Obama's economic
advisers where he stood up and mm I
think it's 2010 2011 the guy's name is
Jason Foreman and people were
complaining
during the recession then that followed
the banking crisis
about the cost 11 and he said yeah but
the cost of like things like technology
goods are falling all the time I mean
iPods are incredibly cheap and somebody
show it out you can't eat an iPod
[ __ ] if you're the bottom end of the
income distribution which in British
terms of bottom 40% right you're not
earning any more than eating quite
another now think about all the costs
that you have to put into a normal
person's life yeah it's great the
technology's made us more connected but
if I've got three kids and I've got to
get them off cell phones that look like
this and I've got a piece of those plans
to keep them connected a lot of
financial stress out the only cause of
this stuff a mark one of the points you
make as well just because as we wrap up
talking about prior to Cove it is I want
to just briefly talk about the crash and
the crisis of 2008 because one of the
things that I've often been talking
about is we're massively indebted as a
country but one of the things you talk
about in the book is actually this idea
that you know we spent too much as
people as individuals and that's why
we're so in debt is complete rubbish
actually what happened is we bailed out
the very people who got us into trouble
using the money of ordinary people so
talk to us a little bit about that yes
yeah I mean you just nailed it right
there if you look at average we see
direct country debt from 2000 to 2008
going down because economies of growing
and so long as the economy is growing
faster than the rate of growth in your
debt stock the debt shrinks so think of
it like a fraction right numerator
denominator you denominator is debt your
numerators your economy if your economy
is going faster than your debt stock
it's gonna shrink right so that's what
was going on then there's an almighty
banking crisis and you basically buffer
the recession bill the banks provide
them with equity do all the stuff you
need to do you get a 30% jump in GDP in
terms of debt to GDP and then George
Osborne comes out and goes oh my god
Labor's been spending like drunken
sailors it [ __ ] all the deal with them
it was bailing a banking system and I
think that's true
go check every other country's balance
sheet because exactly the same thing
happens the Americans got 40 percent
everybody with a big financial sector
ends up bailing out in a costume by 30
or 40 percent in GDP that
all the quote-unquote debt came from
know if you don't debt let's stay with
that for a minute
right all this terrible debts worse than
ever blah blah blah who's buying all
that [ __ ] it's the rich
it's the 1% it's the banks because at
the end of the day government debt is
the bottom of the credit pyramid it's
what you then lever up to do all the
other things you want to do from lending
for a mortgage to derivatives to
anything else there's never been a
failed bond auction for Starlin there's
never been a failed bond option for US
Treasuries so the same people are
holding this stuff and making an
interest rate offer at least until very
recently are the ones who are going oh
my god this is terrible
right that to me just oh hang on a
minute right let me see you're the one
is holding the AH say and you're telling
me you're terrified of it yeah that's
[ __ ] so just to summarize them to
just for people who may not be expert
economists what you're really saying is
we have stagnating or even falling wages
for ordinary people we have socialism
for the rich when they [ __ ] up we bail
them out using the money of the ordinary
people who've been losing out this whole
time and that's where you get more
inequality and more unfairness and
therefore more anger okay and then
combined once the books what you do in
bread and then anybody wants the second
standard the sakes of the walk on this
you think things like Preston Council up
north they lost almost the Thunder their
budget during the austerity years what
is Preston make not a lot it's one of
the most depressed areas in the country
how much austerity was done in London
practically none what's the only bit of
the content is growing London I mean it
wasn't just across incomes it was across
geographies the way that this play dough
and it was what a lot of the anger
behind Brad said you remember the
bedroom tax I mean let's just think
about how [ __ ] insane that was right
basically you live in a [ __ ] part of the
country you have no assets but you have
a bedroom I'm going to use that as an
excuse to basically cut whatever
benefits you've got that's it but
everything will the bar cannot period is
crazy us all right that's where we were
now now take us through to covered cover
hits what's now what's happening now so
there's a film that I can send you guys
which is I'm gonna get neck out next
week which inks
couple on your on the website for the
podcast and now we explain this a film
you can in Spain like this so much that
she made a film around I call it the
Volvo and the master so bear with me you
know tell you the story
I Drive a Volvo because I'm a white
bourgeois get true I've also got a
Golden Retriever
I have literally become everything I
hate right so this Volvo was covered in
ear bugs it's quite fast but you don't
drive a fast cuz it's a Volvo and it's
got loads of ear buds to be crushing it
you'll probably survive basically it's
kind of the automotive equivalent to a
European welfare state costs a fortune
to run Lords the safeties and
redundancies if you crash a nut thing
you'll be fine
here's the American economy until
certain extent the British economy it's
a five liter Mustang g/t everything's
great so long as it's going to a pelt
known as straight road it's end gear
there's no bumps on the road and you're
just going because let's face it that's
a lot of fun if you try and break that
thing if you tell the entire economy to
slam on the brakes and go down for three
months boom the whole thing just falls
apart if you think about this in terms
of what quantum is called growth models
right what's the underlying bit of
what's called gross value I did you
tickle if you will to get growth in the
economy for the Germans it's autos
selling BMWs the rest the world right so
the Greeks is getting people a comment
at the country and sit on the beaches
and sell them drexina right that's how
you do it right for Everly it's tourism
round all the Roman monuments
what is it the America does 25% in
global economy it does a little bit of
anything but it's tight it's tightly
coupled
eighty million American workers are
hourly employees none of them have any
starts - 30 sec payer benefits right you
tell them to go home for three months
and everybody goes hey isn't it the case
that 40% of Americans would have a real
trouble getting 400 bucks together a
right short notice yeah
well that was three months ago so
they're now screwed right there are five
mile long queues for food banks in the
u.s. at the moment right people are
driving there but the only reason the
driving us because they all hire the
cars at least their cars if the
unemployment benefits feel if the
economy doesn't pick up that SUVs going
to go back to the repo guy
how are you going to get to the food
bank at that point all the wheels come
off European systems they cost a fortune
there may be a disincentive effect they
don't create the type of dynamic
economies you get with a Mustang but
when you crush you'll probably survive
that's the world of cooler but I suppose
the most things better for picking up
women don't depend certain type right if
you're signalling lifetime earnings
safety and security a top-line Volvo is
definitely yeah if you like
let's go mental then yes I suppose a
Mustang would be that oddly enough I own
both we know which one of the Francis
prefers but so what you're saying really
is that America is treat teetering on
the edge of a precipice at the moment
because if people can't eat that's and
as somebody who comes from back
Venezuelan background that's a moment
when social unrest happens oh yes
exactly
I'm running a giant natural experiment
no by basically opening up and the
reason we're opening up is because you
can't shut this down it's the Mustang
right it's not a Volvo
so you open all this up and then you
remember things like well Texas right so
Texas only 18 percent of Texans had no
health insurance everybody else has them
insurance through their employer 30
percent of that I mean that are now
unemployed which means huge amounts of
people who are no longer social
distancing who maybe getting infected
have no health coverage that's gonna go
well now it may be the case we simply
don't know that the undergo bottle that
numerator/denominator thing and think
about the cool vote right if if you're
under liner e if passive infection
asymptomatic infection is much wider
than we think
then all these people weren't doing ship
dust no it's kind of brilliant because
what it's doing is it's going to show us
that's the case and that means that the
denominator expands so the numerator
shrinks or lethality goes down which
basically makes everyone go hey it's not
so deadly
we'll be fine we could open two skills
we can get back to work you can start up
the Mustang right F on the other hands
four to six weeks from now we find in
Texas Georgia and all these places that
are
basically abandoning of all showing and
good mark going for it that the the
models that see hardly anybody's been
infected that this is hyper infectious
that 10% of cases result in
hospitalizations while then you're in
trouble because then you would have to
shut down the economy again and you
don't have any of those european-style
ill bucks so how you gonna feed people
you're gonna put them on out
unemployment through June take them off
June and then put them back in September
what are they going to do in the interim
period because if you could open the
economy but what happens if nobody comes
because everyone's freaked out Wow and
so what would that mean later on for the
Trump election do you think because he's
banking on the fact that you know his
major could card is that hey the economy
is great America is working let's go
again if if he gets it right in the
sense it's a binary bet right it's 50/50
either you open up in your Nokia or just
your terminal anyway right so he's got
nothing to lose in terms of terminal
anyway if he continues on this it can
only be bad for him my social distance
and all the rest of it so you might as
well go for it if he goes for any
tongues out he's right he went no doubt
about it because of that point in time
people turn and go God there you are
again those in elites
oh yes sciency I didn't know [ __ ]
because look we went out dead stuff and
it was fine right but all this you have
this plays out and with justification
right F on the other hand it goes
pear-shaped right then you've got a real
problem let's say that there's big
Sargent cases through the summer and
there's a second wave and it really
shuts everything down again do you even
have an election what do you do with
pre-sex there's huge bottles over here
about the right to do mail and vote in
California is in the crossfire for this
one today other states will be trying
this there's a lot of contention around
this election so in terms of what
happens if we open up and things go well
then Trump wins if we open up and things
go badly I don't even know if we have an
election that's really interesting
and Mark you mentioned there least let
me ask you this and I look obviously
you're not a medical expert so I'm not
asking you from the medical point of
view but do you think one of the reasons
that you know we've taken what a largely
unprecedented measures with this
lockdown and that's
where they can see bandied about a lot
unprecedented right but we've taken
these measures do you think we would
have taken these measures quite so
readily had it not been the fact that
the people who are making them are all
middle class like the three of us and
are quite happy to to sit and have have
a you know we're working from home etc
like chief some of those people that
were making those decisions of the
people who aren't employed now do you
think we would have been quite as keen
to go into lockdown that's a really
great question I mean part of me wants
to say no we would and I think that
that's kind of true because the people
who do make these decisions can walk
from home and have the economic
resources and family networks and other
things to make it happen right
even Dominic Cummings had to basically
hand off his kids to his parents 200
miles away right but he could do that he
probably drove their an evolve all right
so you know if you're if you have those
things then yes it's a lot easier but
here's the question on the other side
it's not as if people who are who don't
have those resources or investor at
gamblers if at the end of the day caught
one of the big correlates of lower
income tends to be poor health tends to
be weight gain tends to be underlying
comorbidities such as diabetes etc
particularly amongst minority
populations then would you be willing to
say hey these guys we're not gonna do
that lock don't think you should just go
back to work but there's a preference
one in ten on average will end up in
hospital from your demographic maybe
even higher and you might actually end
up dead you want to go for it so again
the class skewness in the end comes
using credible people like us are highly
and likely to die from this and what's
even more crazy in this one is I
downloaded the audacity to the Office of
National Statistics for the UK I
encourage everybody to do this amazing
just type in ons UK covert 19 death
right you'll find it open it up in Excel
and then just look along at the age
profile this is the bet that blew me
away and this is the April figures do
you know how many people under the age
of 45 have died from this it's like 200
or something in it yeah it's 500 by and
then so what's the tall death forgot
the end of April is left 30,000 the each
skew is incredible right
guests were also skews with age poverty
all these things are tied in together so
making a simple decision about this is
never simple
and the one thing that I'm really
concerned about mark is the long term
implications of this for the British and
the American economies I read a stat I
think was a couple of days ago that
Britain spent more in April on the spend
more in April than it did in the whole
of 2019 and you're thinking I'm thinking
to myself this is simply not sustainable
we can't carry on like this well yes and
no because there's always the Americans
of a great phrase for this which is the
most attractive horse in the glue
factory so here's what happened on March
18th when the British government
unexpectedly came out and said we're
gonna support 80 percent of wages which
is exactly what you should do because
given people checks and all this sort of
[ __ ] is just Columbus um it doesn't work
right now it's on the assumption that
this all last maybe three months and
then we can get back that's an open
question that's where I think
sustainability comes into it but here's
what happened sterling fell 5% point 1 5
percent and the gilt market they're not
the government born market prices went
down yields started to spike and this is
almost as if the financial markets what
like saying you're gonna spend how much
are you kidding me right within two
hours they stabilized why because
everybody else was doing exactly the
same thing so it's all relative and at
the end of the day do you want to buy
stocks just no do you want to buy bonds
because at the end of the day the
government the United Kingdom regardless
who's running it will be there in five
years will Virgin Atlantic be there in
five years will it be there in five
months what happens to Google if
basically at the endless we decide that
is too powerful we we break up or what
happens to Amazon if we decide that
basically there are warehouses of public
health hazards and we shut down their
business model at that point in time
those equities lose value and if we're
still in a panic the fear index is
simple people want debt they want to
hold those
bonds because they are promises to pay
fixed income over a period so long as
you basically think the dollar has value
sterling has a value and on a relative
basis it does because what else you're
going to buy of the you're gonna buy
euros well harms of the Italians block
the whole project you can't buy any
Chinese external assets they won't let
you so at the end of the day this is
sustainable because everybody else is in
an unsustainable position the relative
trade let me ask you this because we
talk to economists a lot I'd like to
think I'm reasonably intelligent I
studied economics at university I should
be able to understand this but every
time we have this conversation I've
always got this thing in the back of my
head as I'm looking at it as an ordinary
person I'm going how can we forever
spend more than we earn and then
suddenly borrow more to bail out the
banks and then ten years later we're now
bailing out ourselves we're paying
people not to work short like if I'm an
ordinary person I'm thinking that
doesn't make any sense does it right
well I mean this is all about my book
before last the austerity but you're not
a household basically you don't get to
print the asset you spend and the way
that government's work is they tend to
spend things and then retrospectively
raise the taxes the poor and poor pay
for them if they don't pay for them
they're on a deficit to cover the
deficit the issue debt which is why you
get there if you have too much debt and
people can swap over them because they
don't think it's going to be paid back
or there's going to be what they call a
haircut on its value then yeah you're
running risks but in the current moment
everybody's screwed so if you swear to
her Brett what are you gonna do you're
gonna buy some you know that probably
more hammered you're gonna buy some
Dutch debt was too thinly traded not
that Dina stares too thinly traded there
aren't enough bonds right so on the one
hand you're right you can't pile debt
upon debt but what actually cures that
at the end of the day is growth now my
worry comes in on this side right so I
don't really worry about five years from
now where the United States will be this
being this would be a horrible period
don't get me wrong right but I don't
think the u.s. is gonna disappear even
if Trump is in charge right we're not
worried about is Italy so Italy is a
country that has the third biggest bond
market in the world
and it's got about the eleventh or 17th
beggar
economy that's not good right and
they've spent like everybody else an
extra 30% because of Karuna so that's
gonna blow all the way out now they
don't have their own currency which
means that they can't build their own
banks which means that they are
dependent on the goodwill of the ECB
buying Italian debt to keep the yields
down the German Constitutional Court
last week said you guys in the ECB
shouldn't do that [ __ ] so they've made
up a new thing this week which is the
franco-german parked that basically says
they're going to issue debt new debt
through the European Commission and
we're going to help the corona affected
economies with this that's all kind of
like smoke and mirrors and rearranging
the deck chairs on the Titanic at the
end of the day Italy is a huge problem
because unlike under the United States
it doesn't ask you to in common sit
right therefore it doesn't actually
control its ability to bail its own
banks or bail its own economy if you
have that sovereign capacity you can
[ __ ] it up don't get me wrong right you
can go full Venezuela but remember to go
Venezuela you need to be a reliant for
ninety six percent of your income on one
thing called oil and then when the price
goes down you're totally stuffed that's
not the British economy so it's not
quite as black and white is that
particularly in this current moment
I worry about if you have an economy
that doesn't grow fast enough and you
have a lot of debt you will end up in
trouble if you have economy with a lot
of debt if you can grow fast enough
eventually it shrinks so I guess the
next question leading onto this is what
is going to be the implications for the
EU because there's already a lot of
discontent we're going to swimming
around in countries like Spain Italy
Greece we've seen with the rise of
populism do you think that if things go
badly in Italy that CERN that parts of
the EU could disintegrate so I was not
someone who thought brags that was a
great idea in the sense that the most
pressing problems of the British
political economy would be addressed by
leaving the EU right you're better off
over because that's a [ __ ] sure it's a
that's what I always said in Francis and
I both voted remain but do the one thing
I was trying to remind people on our
side is
you may think that leaving is not a good
idea but what you're failing to take
into account is the long-term
consequences of stay what's the cost of
staying so the first Canadian Nicole
mine for this was the defenestration of
Greece through his banking system in
2015
remember that summer when they were just
limited in how much people could take
out the ATMs just to totally undermine
the government right so playing pure
politics right now think about southern
Europe as a whole they've barely come
out of a ten year long desertion all
right all how many Italians have you met
in London Lords right why because I'm
not standing because there's no jobs so
they all move to the countries that have
the jobs which means that the societies
are older the dynamic part of the
population is already gone they've got
too much debt they haven't grown in 20
years right and then the eudicots
basically come along in a corona moment
and say well you know we can't really go
around bailing people out it's like well
hang on a minute mate the reason you're
sell in BMWs to the rest the world is
precisely because we are getting
squeezed here in the south you're
running while economy is called the
external surplus that means there has to
be an internal deficit somewhere and
that's what we and Everly in fronts and
spade and mana run you've got all these
rules that say everyone s there on a
balanced budget which means that Emily's
been running a surplus budget surplus
for 20 years now for all the people who
say that's a problem you should run a
surplus look at the Germans well
actually the Italians have won assault
was twice as long and they haven't gone
in 20 years so your debts not your
problem
it's your lack of growth that's a
problem and how much responsibility does
the euro have for this situation because
to me I'll again I'm not an economist
but to me you've got all these different
types of economy so you said based on
you know certain industries and they've
all got the same currency you know to me
seem talking nonsense
yeah absolutely not one interest rate
that's also a nonsense there's
absolutely no way than the interest rate
they've got low enough for the Italians
and it's probably to law for the Germans
so it's look one way to think about it
is you have natural economies because
the adjust of shocks in different ways
right so when your head with a big
common shop like Colvard right if you
are national economies with national
currencies you can do your own thing we
the Americans
their own things we've thought really
but we could do our own thing if you're
the Italians very limited in what you
can do because you don't have that
printing press to respond to it it's
more rearranged than those already
stressed deck chairs on the Titanic then
you think about the fact that you've got
all these different business cycles etc
that are linked to each other and they
become super linked because of the Euro
so the countries that are growing grew
in a certain way like the Germans in the
Eastern European countries basically the
supply chain goes from Eastern Europe
ended germany has assembled as autos and
machine parts an insult to the Chinese
and the Americans the only what for them
that's not what's going on in Italy they
don't have a growth model would it be a
good idea for them and get out yes
but then you get the Hotel California
problem you can check in but you can
never check out so margin Constantine
that you'll italian with money stop
stereotyping me I know I look Italian
but believe me I know Italians you look
like Francis I love the way you manage
to praise me and insult Francis in one
sentence that's what we like you're
Italian with money right and you'll
Italian and basically you're unemployed
you don't have any money and along comes
some populist and says bus there were
plan enough let's get out of the euro
because then we would be able to grow
we'll be able to devalue and have it on
come say we could bail it on box you go
yes that's brilliant you say this is the
worst idea I've ever heard because all
the assets that you have are in euros so
what you're gonna do is you're gonna go
to Germany and open up a bank account
because you can as an EU citizen and
you're gonna move all your Italian euros
which are euro euros into a German bank
account and that means when the Italian
government comes in and says we're gonna
have a new leader you're gonna say yeah
but you're not making out of my bloody
euros so the this problem of capital
flight within the common currency the
minute you try this estimates that Simon
Telford is an economist and I did for
this a few years ago the Italians are
probably destroy between 40 to 50
percent of national wealth and national
savings if they tried to exit the you
know Wow yeah exactly so basically
you're checked it in the hotel
California aren't you
find out your interview and abusive
monitor so essentially it made sound
sorry I don't mean to be each technical
language but it just sounds like they're
[ __ ] either way really well you know
we don't have to stress the technical
aspect of this so much I would say deal
possession how about that yeah are you
running for office anytime soon that was
the most political answer I've been
watching because you know everybody's
watching short lot them I started what
re watching all of Yes Minister
mmm yeah it's actually just as good no
and you could almost there was one
episode I was watching I was like holy
[ __ ] that's the day that stuff never
changes long-term implications for Italy
for Spain for Greece is it just gonna be
that they're just gonna continue to
deteriorate because isn't that
unsustainable you can't do keep doing
that I think that's pretty much it and
you know a few years ago just eggless
The Economist suggested that you have a
dual util right northern you know a
southern you know I don't know how you
get there but if you could wake up
overnight with like two different
currencies with two different relative
values it would actually like probably
be a good idea the problem is getting
out yeah it really is about bad
moderates right because at the end of
the day even if the Northern Europeans
are like we've I don't know if you
people you don't grow you're always
eating bailout all right do the other
way around right if you say that too
loudly the markets look at Italian debt
and go they're not gonna back this [ __ ]
anymore are they and if that happens you
will get that huge yield spike that even
the ECB would deal with and then the
bottom falls out the italian-born market
given a nice denominated in Euros what's
that going to do to all other you know
denominated that's oops so I can
threaten you you can threaten me but
it's a mutual suicide pact fun and games
look enough about the Europeans we left
for a reason breaks it new pretzel let's
exit means let's get it done my favorite
one is get it done cuz it sounds so good
but I don't feel what it actually means
because get it done means now we'll
spend two years talking about what we
actually want to do because we don't
really know right well we're about to
find out or maybe not who knows what
means but you said when we were talking
about the impact of the coronavirus she
said the next period is gonna be
horrible
what do you mean by that mark what are
you talking about
all right so think about it this way and
this is particularly true the United
States but it's true everywhere but
other places are Volvo's are not better
a box right so do you guys ever get
therapeutic massages yeah yeah I don't
don't know Frances not that smile
immediately he thought happy endings a
minute I said that
banana and a half Anakin confined space
with poor air circulation so that's bad
let's see movie theaters yeah I just sat
in there with hundreds of people
coughing and spluttering into the air
that's a good one so when you have like
the US and the UK with very very large
service driven economies and a lot of
those are personal services there are
relatively low wage employers and a huge
number of them don't come back because
the u.s. is current 22 percent
unemployment which is insane is
massively concentrated in those sectors
so if we are in that second world where
the lock turns with the end of a lot of
times don't work and we go into that
every sector is affected but at the same
time some sectors are gonna be massively
affected more than others hold on but
that's a very very pessimistic view at
least from what I'm seeing at this point
what in terms of the medical situation
I'm not sure it's gonna go that way so
let's say that we start to open up the
infection rate goes down progressively
by by September October we work well on
our way towards being back to where we
were before did do we avoid a disaster
then yeah absolutely we do because
what's key here is the length of time
that you do lock don't you have to do it
two or three times if you have a second
wave or a third wave think of the
behavioral response just now I'm a
little bit skeptical about going out for
a pint but I'm all really wanted right
I'm a wee bit skeptical about going to
see my beloved Everton next time I fly
to the United Kingdom but I really want
to if you guys suffer three waves of
lockdowns and there's food riots in the
streets I'm not gonna do any of that
stuff so it's all about how long it
lasts the number of waves in the
behavior response if we get one
everybody puts a discount on it boom
will be back it's fine
maybe not to cruise ships because they
will giant floating petri dishes of
sickness anyway there was a different
box but to everyone else yeah that can
pretty much come back sir really hope
that that's true but if it's not then
that behavioral response is gonna tar
pen and a lot of those jobs and a lot of
those sectors simply aren't one at a
time and they're all concentrated at the
back end of the income this
that's the problem if you were stuff in
rich people they have assets they can
liquidate them they can do stuff they're
mobile right you're poor doesn't want
like that and so what we're going to be
the implications on society then if that
happens don't be pretty but look I think
at this point I mean we don't know for
certain but it's not looking like the
most pessimistic scenario we'll play oh
no absolutely don't know you didn't
bring me on for my sunny disposition
right I am from Dundee we're not exactly
known as the happiest people in the
world sorry Don Dorian's if you're
watching you know it's true
but no I mean this is how I think about
I tend to think about what's the kind of
the that if you will in the distribution
the teal what's going on in the tail
what's the boss what's the stuff that
can really hurt you if you're not paying
attention to her right I've been deeply
affected by Nassim Taleb over the years
not just the Black Swan the whole way
that he thinks and I tend to look far
out in the tail and say okay if we end
up there how bad can it get and what do
I need to do to think about how to get
away from that shock so you know that's
what this conversation threatened
I hope I'm completely wrong I'm one of
the few economist you'll ever meet who's
delighted when he's wrong all the time
yeah that makes sense but with this
let's say we're not looking at the tail
we're looking towards the middle of the
most probable scenario you can't do what
you do another distribution that's for
those point right all right well just
humor me no I get but let's just take
plague go with me on this which is let's
say broadly speaking September October
we're well on our way there is no
massive second wave we find that most
people or a lot of people have already
had it we eventually get to lead to this
evil herd immunity that that everyone
misunderstands etc but we've got enough
people that have had it we're not
catching it again we're all in our way
have what is the impact of the economic
measures we've taken so far are we gonna
see another power of austerity which
according to your way of thinking is
counterproductive anyway are we going to
see taxes go up spending go down or does
the government need to just try and
their way out of this so the way that
angle economies usually adjust is
through a combination of guarantee the
banking system to keep payments going
austerity and budgets to basically
stabilize that stocks and then
unemployment and that works it's brutal
it hot some people more than others but
that's kind of our model that's how we
do it the Europeans don't do that they
have bigger in different air box they
basically have less unemployment they do
a little bit through debt but mainly
they do it through basically hiding
unemployment by declaring people you
know early retirement schemes at Aulis
ownership right and then more generous
benefits France is a typical example of
this now let's say that we play your
scenario then there will be a dramatic
and rapid recovery in the anglo-american
economies at which point in time
aesthetic would be totally kind of
productive because again if you're Z the
rate of growth your economy is greater
than are there growth in your debt stock
it's shrinking anyway so if you then
start cutting spending you're just gonna
slow down your rate of growth but that's
the kind of [ __ ] stupid stuff we do
so we'll probably do it anyway right in
terms of the way that really no good
idea goes on genuflecting
so well let's see what's happened to the
Europeans for northern Europe
if the Americans recover they start
buying BMWs again so long as Trump
doesn't stack tariffs on them and if
China recovers they do the same thing
and the Europeans will sell to anyone so
they don't care so that's you know
northern unit will do reasonably well
either the big problem once again is
seldom you know Italy went into this
with 12% unemployment no growth for 20
years running a budget surplus if you
have then I've got 30 percent
unemployment and you basically say write
lives no let's have a big austerity
binge
I'm opening a short factory in Italy
there'll be one color for the shot and
it's brown that's the political response
you get well so I mean that is a very
very worrying situation where you
essentially saying that we're gonna see
the rise of fascism again and it's only
made they're not very good at it they
can't really get organized we'll be fine
we'll be nice brown shirts though very
well toe stylish yeah
very well-tailored and I know fearless
Mussolini did make the trains run on
time so you know that's a payoff on some
level what do you think is gonna be the
West we've talked about this with quite
a few economists but it's always good to
hear your opinion what do you think is
gonna be the West's reaction to China do
you think it's gonna be business as
normal or do you think we're gonna see a
backlash against deceptive CCP in the
Chinese so the EU reaction is going to
be one of continuing to the koto by
which I mean if you go back six months
ago the German their Chinese threatened
German car exports in retaliation from
not doing far we and the Germans for
that just a few weeks ago something else
happened which was the EU was going to
be critical of the handling of the virus
crisis in a report the Chinese got wind
of it and said don't even think about it
and it won't not even thinking about it
that's it
the Brits are committed to basically
barking out of the Huawei stuff so what
you're beginning to see is and this is
regardless of what the Trump's President
or not what tech people call the splint
on that rather than the internet it's
going to be our tech versus your tech
our standards versus your standards and
that's the way that the world's going to
go regardless of Korona regardless of
Trump regardless of anything else at the
end of the day the story on this I
prefer comes from a guy called Hellman
Schwartz or at least this is my version
of what he says says look when you think
about the global economy you're thinking
about half a dozen firms in different
sectors are really big they are all the
profits the way they do this is through
huge long global value chains that
manufacture here and assemble there and
all that and tied the taxes somewhere
else right those forms are incredibly
powerful
they control 80% of the gross of value
added in the world right that's what
they make all the money now most of
those forms are Americans
and if that's the case the reason you're
willing to tolerate
multi trillion-dollar deficits the
reason you're willing to invest in
American stocks is because they grow
faster than everybody else and they do
because they control the intellectual
property rights and opinions that make
that extraction possible China is
different from Europe Europe has its own
standards has its own model the Volvo is
not the Mustang they're building their
own mosque
they want to harvest undoes they want to
control the intellectual property rights
they want to be in charge of that space
change China 2025 belt Android all the
rest of it so they're out for your light
PRS essentially they want to set the
standards they want to challenge you if
you do that that is a direct threat to
the American growth model doesn't matter
who's in charge
so basically bumpy road ahead no Marwa
really and what do you think will be the
American response therefore would you
reckon negative to double down and so
right you know we're gonna withdraw from
China our companies are gonna get out
we're gonna go to other places that's
really hard to do so I was talking to
somebody who actually knows how this
stuff worked and she gave me the example
of a cotton bud Factory because we're
thinking about medical supplies just
like you know cotton bud swabs all that
sort of stuff you know covered right
takes you about three years to build a
factory with the certification to make
that [ __ ] just for cotton buds right you
spent 20 to 30 years moving all that
tech abroad you don't bring it back in
three months all right
also it's constantly evolving but the
time you get it back it's probably
redundant so it raises huge questions
for the profitability of firms how you
actually manage this stuff and what you
do with it so it's not clear that you
can turn off globalization that way
because we do have a global economy I
like to put it in the passive voice
globalization is upon you whether you
wish it or not right it's not a choice
it's just there and you can choose at
the margin but that's about it so you've
got fractious politics you've got a
Chinese Communist Party that's always
said that we are legitimate in the eyes
of our people so long as we're growing
fast enough to basically legitimate
there are missions that growth is going
down this year's the first year that
never they don't have a growth target
the cult of G is back it's very much one
guy personalist rural authoritarianism
the movement of Hong Kong could presage
a move against Taiwan if you do then you
really are calling the Americans Bluff
on this one and do you really want to
get into a shooting war with these guys
because when you've got the box up
against the wall the Americans will
react very badly so yeah it could get
very very fraught very quickly all right
Mike well we've got a lay you go
unfortunately but next time
you're in the UK let's let's have a if
we're allowed at that point let's have
another interview in studio but before
we do let you go we've got one more
question for you go ahead it's a
question we always finish with which is
what is the one thing people aren't
talking about but they really should be
talking about is it possible to lead a
full and meaningful life without Premier
League football and the answer of course
is not I think that's exactly right I
think it's going to be really difficult
I'm utterly amazed that when I sweat on
the BBC news on my phone I had the
sports link and they still have pages
and pages of stuff but nothing's
happening yeah it's amazing
and then I read it and I feel so empty
and sort of like content listen and sort
of just like yeah and then I wonder if
I'll ever get rid of that feeling so
there's a very very sad insight into
what middle-aged for men is like and
that's all three of us I mean and we all
agree or not that this is actually a
major problem absolutely I'm a fan so
actually it's probably been a yeah and
on that very happy note from those women
or as a fellow overtone Ian I'm
delighted to hear there's someone worse
than us mark where can people follow you
to check out your work and also tell
everybody where to get the book when it
comes out at M key Blythe on twitter.com
I have a website somewhere but I don't
think of update info level so like don't
even bother with that just MK Blythe on
tour and you'll find me and the book is
available everywhere Waterston's go for
it
we're actually on Amazon is number one
anticipated release in political economy
so go pre-order and make it - one I'll
be even more amazing now we do
thoroughly recommend that both Frances
and I really enjoyed reading it so make
sure you get angry nah mcc's and thank
you very much for watching and we'll see
you very soon with a live stream or
another brilliant interview thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
bigger pot and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word